(curious orchestral music)
- [Host] Pink towers and giant dragons:
sounds like a scene from a fairy tale.
But in this case, it's not.
In the Samphran District sits
one of Thailand's most unique temples.
Wat Samphran is a pink shrine
dedicated to the Buddhist faith
and measures 260 feet, or 80 meters, high,
representing the age
of Buddha when he died.
While the temple is known for
the giant encircling dragon,
it's meaning remains a mystery.
Bhavana Buddho, the founder of the temple,
was inspired to create
the hollow dragon building
during a seven-day fasting meditation.
Construction took only five years.
Visitors can climb the
stairs of the 17-story temple
to touch the dragon's
beard, or they can climb
inside the belly of the beast.
This temple is a must visit for people
looking to discover something
truly one of a kind.
(echoing sonic wave)